as as I change my angle in other words I
don't leave his body there his body's
moving with me you see
with my with my adhesions
so if that doesn't change as I come
around his body moves his body is in is
in me and I'm in his body what's
happening on his upper body is just
wherever I'm touching that's that's your
IP adhesion that's where you're in his
body I do have a lock but I'm not in the
joints
I have a lock here but it's in his body
do you see so Aikido don't attack you
could if you want you could attack The
Joint but here I just I'm using that
joint in the same way that where
wherever I'm touching as I'm in his body
do you understand okay so I'm using the
joint and then I attack the leg